big news ambassador Gordon's son Glenn
testified today I don't know if you saw
that yeah it's huge huge story two of
you know what I'm talking about
cuz that's America in 2019 yeah what
else kisses [ __ ]
no Gordon Salman testified today was a
big deal
if you don't know sanguine is a lifelong
Republican with no prior political
experience who owns a bunch of hotels
yes
afterwards Trump said I hate guys like
that
I'll let you enjoy it for a little bit
okay some jokes deserved you were right
the first time
ambassador Sandlin said he's not close
to President Trump but they have a quote
professional cordial relationship yeah
after hearing this Melania said hey same
as me no today was the fourth day of
public hearings in the impeachment
business that's what I call it all the
news channels covered it and a lot of
them you probably noticed this they put
up these information sidebars to explain
a little bit about the person who's
speaking like this one for congresswoman
Jackie Speier they put up this stuff to
sort of tell you what's going on it's
very useful yeah but I notice that as
these hearings drag on the stats are
getting less and less useful for example
House Republican Attorney Steve castor
check it out it says gets his hair cut
every five to seven minutes
sleeps hanging upside down
cracks every knuckle and joint his body
before making love
Congressman Mike Conaway and if you saw
this think stick talk is a small breath
mint featured in dementia magazines 22
watch once called the cops on a black
jelly bean yeah that's a true story yeah
I don't will me Democratic Council
Daniel Goldman makes a champagne popping
noise when he opens that new carton of
milk
totally knows what boobies look like
definitely did not wet the bed last
night maybe you did Congressman Devon
Nunez can't read cursive computer
password is password his own dog humps
his leg out of pity and finally I won't
have this judgment from you and finally
this show is free all right let's get on
board okay dude I'm not sure I showed up
i shelled out nothing to be here I came
literally no distance and finally Jim
Jordan check it out first words as a
baby word get off my lawn when he orders
fish at a restaurant he asked the waiter
to leave the t-pin had anus sewn shut
for maximum in penetrability that's just
[Applause]